welcome back to another edition of The
Gadget Lab show I'm malko calorie and I
am America Baldwin Robbie you've brought
something quite interesting with a very
complicated name it is very complicated
it's a wireless tag is actually the most
descriptive name of anything ever it's
just what it's named is what it is it's
a wireless type that you can you can
attach two different items in your house
now what it does is it'll measure motion
it'll measure angle and it also measures
the temperature so you can throw these
in your refrigerator and if your
refrigerator it is too hot or too cold
or whatever it'll alert you now how
alert you is it has a base station that
connects to your router and that base
station connects to your smartphone iOS
and Android there's also a web browser
if you don't have a smartphone you can
just check it out that's cool so I just
I basically just wrapped this to
anything in my house that I want to
watch the motion of you know so like if
I have a car or bike or something
that'll tell me when the bike's getting
stolen or my card is leaving the house
exactly they have some pretty good ideas
like you could put it on your garage
door opener which is actually a pretty
good thing I had someone break it to my
garage about six months ago and if I had
this I would have known the garage doors
open while i was in my apartment i could
have run downstairs battled some people
ray I'm shanked and they still would
have stole my bike so you put it on your
pets right you can put on your pets and
also will it'll alert you when something
goes out of range so if you have a
certain range for the to the base
station and you don't want your pet to
go beyond that you can just kind of
stick it on their caller children you
put on children as well right and it'll
also be so if you put it on a remote
control you don't want you know your key
you can touch to all these things you
can have an oddly beat to find those and
if it moves it can also be I so since
I've been moving around now it's beeping
so you can see you can use it you can
have it as sensitive or as non-sensitive
as you want exactly well it's pretty big
and it's kind of bulky I can't really
see the facility of anything like
attaching that to remote control I mean
it's kind of
yeah almost as big as my remote they had
they come with a with a velcro strap so
you can strap it around things and of
course it has these little strings on so
you can stick it on a dog collar yeah so
you could take you could actually take
these off and use it to attach the
things without the velcro straps this is
what it comes with so it'd be clear it
doesn't have like GPS an attorney yeah
it's purely based on its relationship to
movement and to the base station yeah
it's it's movement as a gyroscope angle
and temperature okay oh and temperature
so if you put in a refrigerator you can
actually put in the door of your
refrigerator and it'll measure it'll
keep track of the temperature and
whenever someone opens it so if you have
a late night food dreams and you can't
help it but break into refrigerator how
long how long until they put a camera on
one of these things I don't know
probably pretty soon well packed with
sensors it is Packers own stress and
maybe you know I'm sure it will only
improve over time yeah how much now
they're selling the tags for twelve
dollars each but the base station costs
fifty dollars but you can get 255 tags
attached to the base station not as many
so if you have to hun or 56 and you give
me a call I'm sorry but these are only
twelve dollars so you can buy a whole
bunch of them shove them around your
house turn them off and on hassle the
neighbors with some it's it it's only
limited by your imagination and how
geeky and annoying you want to be
exactly alright well thanks you're
welcome alexander's here hi and I was
wondering what is the most popular
mobile web browser in the world it is a
browser called UC browser I've never
heard of that I'm not surprised so
what's the deal it is a browser owned by
a Chinese company and it's actually the
most popular browser in China in India
and other countries in Asia as well so
what's different about it then like
Safari or Chrome or something so it's a
third-party browser it's not something
that's built into most phones and you
know it's a little bit different
depending on the countries so they are
still in beta or alpha
in the United States but in China they
have like I don't know features that
where you can like zoom in and the text
will you know fit into the screen which
is something that's missing from Safari
and chrome there they're just they're
faster supposedly is what they claim
okay how do they do the fastness trick
do they do like what opera does where
you know these proxies it's actually
based so they say that's how they're
able to like you know send I think data
from a server and then it's there squish
down on and squish it down and sent you
okay so it's so it's similar to what op
operatives with the proxy service um now
on on mobiles in countries that don't
use Roman character sets this is
probably a pretty big deal right zooming
in on text yes like that are now it does
it make a big difference when you look
at English language or Roman character
would baby the nice thing is that you
don't have to scroll horizontally ever
so you're always scrolling vertically oh
that's obviously a lot easier on a tiny
screen like this so that's good I mean
on the iPhone browser that i have
downloaded that's not a feature yet but
that is like one of their main features
in their android based browser
especially in China okay so the thing
that's interesting to me is that you
know there are there are specific user
scenarios that happen in Asia that don't
happen anywhere else in the world and
this browser is tuned to those right you
know circumstances so is it going to be
as successful here or is this just
something that like people who made me
speak Chinese Andrey Chinese are gonna
want to download I think that they're
trying to make a browser specifically
for the US market and right now they are
you know the most popular browser in
China and that's because they cater to
specifically the Chinese market so in
China let's say you know red is actually
a good color in China so when stocks are
going up they have a red like red behind
them but in the United States red is bad
so they have these local teams that
basically focus on specific user
experiences of certain location
and so that's what they're trying to do
in the u.s. they're trying they're still
researching what the US market wants and
then that is what they're doing with
their us browser so it would be
different it would not be the same
browser here as it is in China okay well
I mean I'm I'm still curious to download
it and dry it out because I would love
to see what a browser invented on the
other side of the world feels like when
I'm used to one that was invented on
this side of the world and I think
what's different in China is that they
mostly access the internet through
mobile devices really so that's why it's
so important for them to have this
browser looks fast and I mean most of us
in the u.s. just like use whatever is
built in on our bones so safari on an
iphone or chrome so what about tablets
does it does it have all the same mojo
on something like an iPad or is there an
ipad version there's not i don't think
right now so they're not really a tablet
focus browser so it's specifically tuned
to smaller else else yeah well speaking
of tablets and smartphone applications
you should mention that on thursday
facebook announced a new app a new
version of its app and it's so fast so
they claim so the big complaint about
the old facebook app is that it was
really slow and i think a lot of that
had to do the fact it was non native
code right and it's all web based code
all right so this is a native version of
the app and it is much faster you know
when you're when you're doing things
like zipping through photos we're using
Nathan Oh leave our as Giles as our
subject here but when you're when you're
flipping through photos it's just it's
smoother there's no herky-jerky pneus
that there was on previous versions and
supposedly you know just on the iphone
the same thing you can scroll through
the newsfeed much faster you know before
it would just you know it would take
forever to load yes sometimes so long
that I've just closed the facebook app
and now it's two times faster as what
they claim for me I just think it's
noticeably faster I was always using
touch facebook com oh there there mobile
yeah I never use the app because it was
just I couldn't stand it but you know
having done
playing around with it for a few hours
it's actually like I'm finding myself
doing something that I never do which is
use Facebook to look at other peoples
pictures and read their status updates
yeah so I guess in that respect it's
sort of a success huge so he took a long
time yeah how long has it been years
yeah well you should definitely download
it if your Facebook fan it's something
you do not want to miss out on download
it now and that's all we have time for
this week yep so we'll see you next week
on the casual AB